okay so here we are eating your feed the
show where
the man behind the camera adam makes
people make
food that they've seen in viral internet
videos
today we're going to be making the
flaming hot cheeto burrito
so this restaurant sayulitas and they
make apparently
many of their popular menu items with
flaming hot cheetos but today we're
interested in the burrito
and the burrito is that big carne asada
a liquid avocado sour cream a
bunch of flaming hot cheetos in a scoop
of liquid cheese to help me out i have
really
tasty producer chef extraordinaire any
other anything else you want me to call
out
your friend hubby friend yeah we're a
friend today i'm making
this the size of a kitten
it's a pretty massive kitten actually
it doesn't have rice and beans that's
what i noticed too
maybe there's something to that
combination anything you think i should
watch out for
i think since there are lots of
ingredients
make sure season everything well
hopefully i can just have a
perfect burrito to present first up
we're gonna start by
marinating the beef i think this is
wolfgang puck's apron
i made a video with him two years ago
and he left his apron behind hopefully
he never watches this video
i have 1.89 pounds of black
meat i also got this because on the
internet and you're bad at cooking you
want lots of little tricks you go like
that
now you can stick all of your
ingredients in there
and it stands up straight nice new
cutting board
so i'm kind of making this one up too i
mean it doesn't matter like just put
tasty liquids and
spices in a tub and you put the meat in
there and then you're good to go right
so we're going to start by
juicing some limes in this orange you
know that trick
oh it releases the juice
you start by rolling the lime and then
we'll cut it
and we'll take this thing
people watching this video are enjoying
the speed at which this is happening but
in real life it took many minutes
shut up oh this was a juicy you hear
that
all right that's gonna be enough juice
oh yeah
so we got our juices goes into the bag
garlic do like five cloves i'll add
a bunch of cumin that much chipotle
chili powder a lot of recipes call for
some kind of other smoky pepper type
thing we have this ancho
chili a bunch of salt oregano next i'm
going to take cilantro
the silliest of the herbs get it people
are laughing like this much
your cutting board does that it's not
safe
put some olive oil in too to kind of
smells pretty good
okay in my meat goes
and now we got a bag of meat
this will go in the fridge for at least
an hour
okay so it's time to start making to try
making tortillas these are gonna be
flour tortillas
you know there's a ton of recipes for
this it's
flour a fat and salt essentially some
call for baking powder
most ask for a little bit of water or
some ass for milk i'm gonna start with
three cups of flour here
teaspoon of baking powder some salt in
here we failed to buy a lard but i did
manage to buy duck fat it's like if you
if you made
fat into a butter look at that smells
like a bird
it's like melting from the warmth of my
hand adam asks if that's the name of my
memoir
oh not an exact measurement four
wads of that so now i'm going to start
clumping this by hand
ooh that's a weird feeling
it said use warm water it's already
busting to move here
oh that might have been a mistake why
did i do that give me some more flour
i it became very wet now i'm trying to
balance it back out with some
flour i'm a total dough noob by the way
in every video that we do where i have
to
do a dough
okay i think this is actually going
pretty good the dough is bouncing back
[Music]
i'm gonna wrap this in plastic so that
moisture doesn't escape give that an
hour to rest since we're making a spicy
burrito today
i thought why don't i have a spicy beer
cocktail as well
so we're going to make a michelada real
quick i'm referencing a bon appetit
article
it's called how they make micheladas in
mexico i'm gonna juice some limes i
found a better juicer this time
oh yeah this is like a spicy salt with a
little bit
lime juice oh yeah
yeah look at that nailed it his is for a
big batch so i'm just kind of making up
the proportions
yeah a little hot sauce dash of
worcestershire
thai oh i guess i'll do ice next so this
is a
tomatoey clam juice and for this it's
pretty much just one to one
with the gear just pretend that that
ratio is perfect
it's delightful we're gonna start
rolling out the dough that we made
there's some white spots on here that i
hope
are just the the pieces of fat
see how big we can get this stuff it's
so squishy
it this is amazing feeling i'm just
going to try to get a basic
circle shape which i think we've all
been in an art class where we tried to
draw a circle and it's just the hardest
thing ever so
god how do you get a circle out of this
it feels nice and
thin and light i think i'm going to fire
up
my griddle and just see how this cooks
oh yeah it's good
got some stuff happening already over
here stuff is puffing i think i'm just
gonna have to turn this a lot
oh god oh it's so hot i'll keep my hand
on here until it's time to turn it
oh yeah that's what that's what i want
look at that
it's definitely like the doneness of a
quesadilla at the moment so i think if i
tried to roll this it would not go too
great
yeah i mean i think if i did this again
but just flipped it fewer times so it
didn't dry out
so we're gonna make our cheese sauce now
little roux
action like you'll rue the day that you
were born
adam bianchi i perfected this technique
making cheesy hamburgers
adding the cheese is so much fun i'm
having a hard time stopping
[Music]
all right oh
i think it's broken cheese sauce attempt
too
so i'm actually going to take my milk
and warm it in the pot first
in the meantime i'm gonna grate this
cheese put this back in here
two tablespoons of butter three
tablespoons flour
this ratio looks a lot better this time
okay now i'm gonna slowly add the milk
and just pour it everywhere at the same
time
scalding milk underneath the pot that's
good i wonder if i could blot up this
milk without setting a paper towel on
fire nope
okay that'll take another minute
it's cheese time here
way more togetherness on the spoon
creamy texture okay so that's a cheese
sauce
oh here's a good idea take some of my
leftover
tortilla test morenay fondito we just
stopped the video right here
one thing i am gonna do is pull our meat
out of the fridge
so it cannot be super cold when we're
trying to cook it i think i'm also gonna
pull it out of the marinade
so that it can be a little drier time to
avocado sauce so the guacamole that's in
the video
was pretty much just a super creamy
green sauce i think i'm just gonna do
avocados and lime juice
a little salt oh that's a lot
i think it's fine it's time to grill
some meat
we have a hot cast iron here and there
it is
i'm basically using this like i would if
i were grilling i feel pretty good about
this
boom first flap down
we're gonna let it rest in some foil
until we're ready to slice
all right so here are our neon
spicy cheese crunchies aka
flamin hot cheetos little taste test
i mean they're so good the meat has
rested we're gonna slice into it now to
kind of match
what was happening in the video we'll
cut them kind of into these strips and
then against the ground like that
give me one second it's like a solid
medium
in the video it was like well done
chunks of meat
but i think this is pretty good i can
have that at them
the time has come to make the perfect
tortilla
to wrap up this burrito video flour
the surface retrieve the dough
a generous portion all right i'm just
gonna go for a mega tortilla with this
one
i'm gonna try to do this one very
carefully
people who know how to make tortillas
are going to be laughing at this video
and just muttered they won't be the only
ones
that's pretty much a perfect tortilla
what do you think it's uh it's big
it'll fold so we're gonna go with it
here we go
beef add a pinch of salt to this because
i
under seasoned it slightly next green
stuff
guacamole is not an extra two dollars
at this burrito place crema which is
satisfying all my fantasies of eating
elmer's glue as a child the good stuff i
don't want them poking holes in my
tortilla that i worked so hard to make
you ready for this one
[Music]
there you have it if that doesn't look
like that
then you're a liar now for this fun part
ooh
i can go
hey rie look what i made burrito
it's not giant was it a giant burrito
it was yeah it was pretty big okay and
the problem is
i could only make a tortilla so big the
most important thing is flavor
that's totally what i was focused on
ready for this adam
oh the color yeah look at that pretty
cheers
cheers i like the crunch
i don't want to automate this is good i
mean
it's cheetos junk food well it's good
well you do keep eating it yeah i think
visually
we pretty much got it i'm actually
surprised at how well these components
work together
i didn't help you at all this time it's
pretty soon i'm going to be coming over
to your videos telling you how to do
stuff
another day in the books you're on
eating your feed adam how about i make
you one
watch this is going to be the best one
the cheese is like as hot as cheese
could possibly be
is this why you only have potato salad
for lunch no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no